Welcome back everyone is Charlie
This'll be my Full
Loki Season 2 Episode 6 Finale Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs,
obviously a huge WTF ending to the series,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos and I will address.
The status of Loki Season three.
Like the future of Loki just in general
in the Marvel Universe, because his new role
makes him basically one of the most powerful beings
in the entire Marvel multiverse.
truly burdened with glorious purpose.
And careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the episode yet, we'll just start at the beginning.
Work our way through shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and the many many WTF moments
starting with the episode title Glorious Purpose,
which is the same title as the very first episode.
The way that they engineered the episode,
it mirrors a lot of moments from the very first episode
show you how much character development
he's had since those moments in episode one.
Because remember, this is like Avengers one era Loki.
this is also meant to reference
his true glory, his purpose, like his actual purpose,
the grander, glorious purpose,
basically becoming the God of stories.
Loki in managing the entire multiverse flow of time,
basically becoming the center of the multiverse.
he was destined for a throne. He was born to it.
They have a moment at the end of the episode
where he kind of echoes that line, like
it's the earlier Loki,
but then he time slips in and he starts to realize
that his throne that he was born for, quote
unquote, is actually God of time.
Loki throne,
there was even a little joke
about that at the end
when he's actually crafting the throne on the rock
where he remains Citadel at the end of time
used to be basically refashioning things
into a golden throne for himself
to sit on God of stories.
Loki is a huge dickhead for the comics,
but the more recent comics.
So I'll explain that
when we get to those parts of the episode.
I know there are all kinds of questions about Avengers
five Kane Dynasty.
Like what does this mean for Loki during Secret Wars?
If he's this powerful don't worry,
we will address that.
the actual opening Marvel Studios
title plays in reverse this time
because we're coming from the end of episode five
and he's basically time
slipping back to the moment before the timeline
exploded.
in it almost sounds like the song that they play over
is a cover of Pink
Floyd's Time from Dark Side of the Moon.
the camera coming back in through The timeline
itself is also meant to show you things
from Loki's perspective, like what it actually kind of
looks like when he's time slipping in the opening
scene is basically us replaying events from episode
four from a reverse perspective.
Like there's a small effect that a sound plays to show
that Loki has slipped back into his position again,
showing us the older version of Loki is now here
then they basically have
what is like a Groundhog's Day for most of the episode
until Loki starts to realize what's actually going on.
they start out watching the same events play over again
and Victor Townley dies again.
R.I.P..
He dies many times, turns out, because all the time
loops all the different tries that Loki makes
in Loki starts looping back and back again and again
and again, trying things just a little bit differently.
some of the tries are meant to be funny,
some are kind of horrific.
there there's a lot there is a lot of spaghetti,
so to speak, in this episode.
when he said again but faster.
That also reminded me of the classic George Lucas joke.
there's this joke that Mark Hamill,
Harrison Ford, Carrie Fisher,
all the original Star Wars
actors used to say about George Lucas,
is that his only real direction to his actors
was again, but faster this time again, but faster.
Over and over again.
they're couple big music and song Easter eggs
during the episode
to the music that kicks in here is Beethoven's
Fifth Symphony,
but the disco version and the reason why they use
this song is because obviously it's really cool song.
but also there's a lot of meaning behind the song
that dovetails with Loki's journey through the episode.
the actual symphony itself
is meant to be about triumph,
like the whole concept of triumph
just in general, about every hard won victory
there's ever been, ever will be basically foreshadowing
the end of the episode when Loki,
after a great effort, is victorious and triumphs
by transforming into the God of stories.
Loki basically managing all of time.
He kind of becomes the God of time,
but not quite like that.
Like, explain his powers
when we get to that part of the episode,
Because I'm sure there will be a lot of questions
about how his new powers work.
but one of the first big questions.
It seems like there's no limit on the amount of times
that he can time
slip and there's no cool down on the ability either.
there a couple more Viktor timely attempts
to make it down the walkway doing different things
in each time and to his credit
each time he makes it like a couple steps further.
Then he starts
time slipping back to earlier points in the timeline.
We're still in the middle of episode four
when this is happening.
Like most of the episode, especially early on, is him
jumping around during the events of episode four.
this is where things start to get a little bit wackier.
Like I loved him interrupting Ren, Slayer
and Miss Minutes who are in the middle of their coup
attempt and Miss Minutes is like, What?
we're in the middle of massacring
all these different people like this is after
she massacred all those people
this time, it almost seems like they dragged
Victor timely down.
They're almost kicking and screaming.
He tries about seven more times.
And his second quote here Loki's quote,
I wasted time and now doth time waste me
is actually from William Shakespeare's Richard,
the second in essence, the full speech from Richard.
The second means the early bird gets the worm,
we just meant to dovetail
with the whole theme of what's happening here.
Like, the faster we go, the better chances of success
we have.
when he says again, for the last time,
he jumps back even further in the timeline to
when they first introduce Victor Timely to Obi, they're
still in the middle of the events of episode four.
Like I said though,
but you can kind of see the progression here.
Like he keeps going back earlier in earlier in earlier
in his own personal timeline of the TVA.
notice during this part of the episode,
Sylvie is the only one to pick up on
how weird Loki has suddenly gotten.
Like, remember, she was also able to retain her
memories from when the timeline blew up the first time.
Maybe that has something to do
with being a variant of Loki and Loki innately
being able to evolve into the God of time
like if that ability was within him.
Maybe some of that ability is also within Sylvie.
Somewhere in there.
so maybe that's part of the reason why she can remember
certain things some of the others can't.
they were about the model. Again,
make a bunch of jokes.
This is obviously a reference to Back to the Future
with the special model.
Like there's only a couple of coats of paint
on. It's a terrible model.
No, no, no. What are you talking about?
It's amazing they kind of have their jokes
about speed running events here.
Like he volunteers Victor Timely.
Who doesn't realize what's going on?
Like, don't worry, you'll volunteer eventually.
And he starts to give away that he knows
some of the things that are happening in the future
Some of them start to pick up on the weirdness
when they sense that he's basically
repeating their dialog as they're saying it, like, Wait
a minute, how did you know what I was going to say?
in they have the joke about Loki basically
using the ability to learn everything in himself.
Like how long would it take me to learn all this
engineering, how time works, basically?
a couple of centuries. Sure. Whatever.
What's a couple of centuries
to somebody who lives 5000 years
And that's the whole idea
that basically be like four or five years to year.
Me So Loki is basically getting a degree
like a four year
college degree, so to speak, in time itself.
when he says he's a fast learner
and he's a guy that's listening.
To foreshadow him becoming the god of stories,
there are a couple moments in the episode
where they either reference other characters, reference
him being a God or he himself references being a God,
just meant to foreshadow the turn.
At the end of the episode.
This time they actually do a
transition to quote unquote, centuries later,
like a couple hundred years.
Hit the fast forward button there.
A couple of moments later in the episode
where you sense that there was like a time jump
that they just did not tell us about, like,
wait a minute, he's done this thousands of more times.
We just didn't see it.
I think the special card here denoting the centuries
that a past is just meant to foreshadow that as well.
then basically the idea is that the end of those couple
hundred years of him learning all those things
about engineering about time is up.
He jumps back in time to this moment
then they go down to the control room.
the couple more jokes about him, speed running,
everything, all the characters also starting
to get a little bit weirder.
Like even cases like, Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Maybe we should test this a little bit when he's
the one to put his head in the temple or a machine,
I actually expected there to be like some twist,
but sure enough, it just says, no, it's not You.
in this time when he's sending Victor
timely down notice that he keeps adding
all little details revealing
that they've actually done this a couple of times
already and failed
like don't put the device on the platform.
It'll roll off. remember to put duct tape here.
Remember to press the button
a couple of times because it sticks.
like I said, basically smash cutting.
Like when you see events
pick up, like when you see him time slipping, he's
actually done things a couple of times before.
We're actually seeing him
so if you really wanted to think about it
if you assumed that he spent a couple thousand years
that he who remains reference
and then he should spend a couple thousand years doing
more loops to you actually get your head around this
if you assume that he actually did that
and they just didn't show us that cut,
then he's probably spent at least like 2500 years
or so at these different time loops.
Before we get to where he is at the end of the episode,
They make it sound like when he time
slips back into his body, like he's literally
taking over the previous version of his body.
so, even if he studied to like the day before,
he would have died of natural causes
if he time slipped back to his body
here, it's only his mind that would be older.
His actual physical body would be whatever age
it is right here.
So theoretically he could live forever
by doing stuff like this movie
is finally starts to call him on all his weirdness
and we finally get to an attempt
where Vader Timely is successful in adding the parts
like the Hotfix to the sacred timeline.
when he comes back, the whole Pumpkins quote sounds like some kind of old timey victory cheer from the 1800s.
Notice that he also
calls Loki a wizard when he greets him again
as he's coming back like O Wizard.
Did it work?
Then in the other shoe drops
and they reveal the whole trick behind the loop.
Like the loom itself cannot be fixed no matter what.
as Victor Timely explains, it's not designed to scale
infinitely with the infinitely growing multiverse.
later in the episode, he remains explains
sort of the whole mechanics behind how this works.
Like even if it explodes, all that's
really happening here is that the loom is resetting,
deleting the extra time lines to maintain
only the sacred timeline.
But while that happens, the collateral damage
is that every time the TVA gets destroyed
and he just rebuilds it after that.
so for example at the end of episode four
when it seems like the timeline explodes
and all of reality explodes with it, In reality,
what was happening is
the loom was just resetting things
in preserving the sacred timeline,
deleting the extra timelines in the process of that,
just wound up destroying the TVA.
so it wasn't all of reality collapsing or dying
or anything like that.
then when Sylvie suggested this is destined to happen,
the minute that all the timelines started branching,
Loki gets the idea to stop her
from killing who remains.
So it's at this point that I think he has not yet
been through all those thousands of different time
loops where he learned how to control time
without any special movements Like there's
a point during his conversation with he remains later
where it seems like he's learned how to do that.
Like when did he learn how to do that?
I think there was like a cut somewhere in his attempts
to stop Sylvia from killing him,
where he sort of pours
things in and spent thousands of years doing that.
But basically he jumps back into time
right before Sylvie was about to kill he who remains
and then tries to talk her out of it and stop or many,
many times there's a little bit of new dialog from
he remains here but like he says later,
he knew that this was going to happen.
So he just kind of watching things play out, kind of
watching Loki follow the path that he laid out for him.
Notice the first time Loki tries to stop her,
she says that he's obsessed with the throne.
Like you want this
because you're so obsessed with getting a throne.
It's obviously meant to foreshadow
the end of the episode.
Like when he says it's the last thing he cares about,
he's being honest with her.
But ironically,
he winds up having to take a throne for himself,
which is why he smirks at the end of the episode
to like that Loki smirk isn't meant to be
an evil smirk, like at the end of Thor,
the dark world It's meant to be him
kind of laughing at Sylvie when she said that
you've been obsessed with the throne this whole time.
In all the times that he told other people
that he was destined for Thrones, it's kind of him
laughing at his situation, kind of laughing at himself
a little bit like, yeah, you were right.
You're right the whole time.
there's a lot a lot of he remains devs
during these time loops though like R.I.P.
he dies several times in the funny thing is too
is this sort of
twist
his dialog from season one when he says See you soon.
it's no longer meant to just be a reference
to the Council of Kangs and all of his variants.
Showing up is meant to be a reference
to Loki seeing him again soon when he time slips again
because he remains, knows all about the time
slipping literally.
Everything that happened
during their conversations in season
one is meant to be him talking to Loki specifically.
But the way they framed the conversations
during season
one made it sound like he was talking to both of them.
then he remains confronts Loki with the idea
that he'll have to kill Sylvie
if he wants to preserve the sacred timeline.
is the one thing he refuses to do,
like he just can't bring himself to do it,
which is why he lets her past him a couple of times.
he remains uses his personal tempered to stop Sylvie
basically put her on pause.
And because he's a kang, he basically knows everything
that's been happening, revealing the whole truth
to Loki earlier in the season
when Miss Minutes was referencing this grand plan
that he who remains had to manage things
in the event of his death.
she was only thinking of Victor timely,
becoming or replacing.
He remains becoming like the new he who remains when.
In reality he remains sort of orchestrating events
to help Loki become the God of stories
So the whole idea is that he probably never fully
trusted Miss Minutes like he never told her
the full plan and she never figured it out.
that's why he starts making fun of Victor timely,
making fun of his stutter, talking
about how the loom is basically useless other than
to preserve the sacred timeline when we were talking
about season one episodes, the whole idea is that he
who remains is the way the producers explained.
They also confirmed this too, is that he was meant
to feel kind of like the Willy Wonka
version of Kang it, if you think about Willy Wonka,
Charlie, the Chocolate Factory story, it's all about
Willy Wonka trying to find and train a replacement
like Luke for the proper replacement,
Which is basically what he was doing.
But it was just for Loki trying to help
Loki put him on this path
to evolve into the God of stories. it
if it wasn't clear
when he's flicking his finger like moving
Sylvie around, like, bring her back, send her away.
Basically, he just rewinding her in her own timeline
she just goes to somewhere
she was in an earlier episode basically confirming
that he never intended on just letting Sylvie kill him.
And for that to stick
like she wasn't going to ever be able to perma kill him
because he knew that this would happen,
events would repeat, Loki would start repeating
his own timeline, slipping around The quote
that Loki has We die with the dying.
We're born with the dead is a T.S.
Eliot quote, The full quote actually goes like this
We die with the dying sea.
They depart and we go with them.
We are born with the Dead Sea.
They return and bring us with them
And it's meant to be him understanding.
He remains Talk about reincarnation
like he says reincarnation.
Maybe within the context of the episode.
The reincarnation is because of all the time loops
This is where we get to the reveal
that we've actually had way more time
loops than they've let on.
In the episode when Loki reveals that
he can actually stop time with a flick of his finger
the way that he was taunted by, he remains early, like,
see if you can do this after a while.
turns out it's already been a while
and they just didn't show us in the episode.
like I said, based on his reactions, I think that
the wild that they just cut out of the episode,
like the missing time period, was at some point
during his fights with Sylvie.
this is like a hidden
cut out there with like 2000 years in it.
then he reveals the true details behind the loom
and how it's
meant to just be a failsafe for the sacred timeline
itself.
It's only ever meant to protect the sacred timeline,
no matter how they alter it.
also interesting is that he doesn't care about the TVA
or anyone in it being destroyed.
Like, we just rebuild. That's no big deal.
I'll just get more variants of those characters.
definitely make him seem way more sinister than he did
in previous seasons in.
It also kind of sounds like Ren
slayer was always his pawn.
Like he never actually really loved her.
Or maybe if he did, it was just briefly
but essentially like later in the episode
when the earlier Mobius from the events of episode
one are telling him that
basically the only reason why he's in this position
is because Ren slayer allowed.
And the real truth is that he who remains
was secretly behind everything and influence ren slayer
so she would do this and put Loki in this position
so that he would evolve into the God of stories.
so as much as he was trying to orchestrate events
and push Loki around is more like
push him down the path that he set out for him.
He was also doing the same thing for Ren, Slayer
for Miss Minutes, for pretty much everybody else
and when he tells Loki
that his variants are already out
there, like there's nothing
that Loki is going to be able to do about them.
He's talking about the Council of Kangs
in how their base is
also outside of time in a pocket dimension,
kind of like the way the TVA exists.
So nothing that Loki does to change the timelines
or create
new timelines or erase timelines
will do anything to affect the Council of Kangs.
we'll get into this in a second too.
When we talk about Avengers
five Kang Dynasty with like God of stories Loki
because now it seems like he has way more power.
Shouldn't he be able to deal with the Council of Kangs?
Explain why that's not the case.
just remember they're in the background
for like the rest of the episode,
then Loki clocks the equation on.
He remains a blackboard and so many people.
After episode six and season one aired, we're asking
about this like what was written on the blackboard.
It was just that a focus in the episode.
So there's like no way you could actually read
everything that was on the board.
but essentially they should use it in this episode
to show you Loki metaphorically saying I'm going to
change the equation like he's going to destroy the loom
and find some other way of fixing things.
Remember,
his goal is different from he who remains goal.
So he remains was trying to preserve
a version of a sacred timeline
that wasn't great, but it was better than the all out
chaos of the came multiverse war.
all that Loki is trying to do is just save his friends.
So it's way easier for him to do that
than just preserve a very specific type of timeline.
suits, basically he remains telling Loki,
you have one of two options in Loki saying, no, no,
I'm going to come up with a third option.
basically he's going to win the game by not playing.
He remains game.
but in order to do that, he has to become the God
of stories, basically sacrifice himself, so to speak.
technically, he's still alive, but he's kind of like
taking himself out of the equation.
Like he has to sit here in this space
at the center of all reality,
at the center of the multiverse
to help maintain it with his power.
No more vacations for Loki
the other funny thing about Loki
may realize in all of this too,
is that he's like the universe's biggest narcissist.
He previously believed himself
to metaphorically be the center of the universe.
Now he's literally the center of the multiverse.
when they bring Sylvie back,
we get some dialog from the earlier trailers
when he remains as around and around
we go make the hard choice.
That was in like one of the very first trailers
Then, instead of killing Sylvie, like he remains
expected him to do, Loki jumps back
to where he was inside the interrogation room
during the events of season one Episode one
now obviously recontextualizing his speech
about wanting a throne, being born for a throne.
now in the new context.
The idea of his glorious purpose is that it was always
for him to become the God of stories,
a much higher calling in of a much higher throne,
so to speak.
basically on the level of like a lot of cosmic beings
in the multiverse, like we're talking
about really, really powerful there, couple straight
Easter eggs here to in the interrogation room,
like the soda that Mobius is drinking
is the now in real life defunct brand called Joss.
That was a real soda.
You could have drunk during the nineties.
it was only sold from 1995 to 1999.
In the joke was the TVA controls all the time.
They can just pluck things out that they want,
even if it goes out of service or it stops being made.
At some point
the TVA can just continue to use it if they want.
let me know in the comments.
Have you ever actually tasted of that soda
when they get to the point where he's repeating
some of his dialog from earlier in references,
glorious purpose, that's obviously meant
to be a reference to the title of the first episode,
but also now the finale in his grander,
glorious purpose.
part of the reason why the title of this episode is
Glory is Purpose, the same as the title of episode one.
Season one is to reference the journey.
Loki's been all like It's come full circle for Loki
and he does actually have
a real glorious purpose
now there's a bunch of new mobius backstory, too.
He tells a story about a hunter
who got a bunch of other hunters killed
when he hesitated to prune
someone in the idea that it was him.
He was the person that hesitated.
He regrets the death of his fellow hunters in Ren's
Slayer was the partner who stepped up and helped him.
It was right after that that she became a judge
and started doing what she's doing now, explaining
what their relationship was during season one.
Like it seemed like they had been old friends
for a while Turns out they used to be partners.
Then they explain why everything is turning
to spaghetti and it's Loki controlling things
outside of time.
I sort of like a side effect of his power
in the way that things are existing here.
Outside of time.
He slips back to the end of episode five and stops time
while Sylvie is talking to him, giving him
the idea that he can replace the sacred timeline
with something more complex
that can handle all the infinitely growing branches
in the multiverse.
basically make it
so that they don't have to prune anyone anymore.
This time he sacrifices himself by going out
on the bridge in references, being a new kind of guy,
which is another reference to him
becoming the God of stories from the comics transforms
his clothing to the God of Stories outfit
based on the promos with a full set of horns.
I also love the fact that he's wearing loafers
like comfy shoes for the God who has everything Notice.
He also opened the doors using his power
and he uses his new power to destroy the loom.
Like that's how powerful he's getting here.
then they are to represent different timelines
as physical branches.
I think that's because they're outside of time.
Like it's a four dimensional Loki
looking at three dimensional time.
that's why he's like literally able to grab a timeline,
like a rope
Essentially in this space
here, Loki is existing in a higher dimension
Then he starts using his new power to bring life
back to the branches, like maintain the branches.
And when he rips open the tear there,
that's basically him ripping
open a hole in this dimension where you can see
he remains citadel at the end of time,
When it seems like he's stepping on an invisible
bridge, stepping towards that rock where he remains.
Citadel was
there just him using his power to create this bridge.
he's basically walking on the concept of time,
Like I said,
it seems like he's physically able to influence time.
but you probably get the metaphor here.
Like he's basically becoming Loki, who remains
but also God of stories.
Loki basically taking he remains place but doing
so with a much better option
than he remains had for him.
he basically transforms.
He who remains previous chair like this is his chair
in his office or what used to be his office
transforms it into a golden throne,
which is meant to be referenced back
when he remains said that he got the big chair
because he made the hard choices.
now Loki is making the ultimate hard choice.
So he gets the big chair, so to speak.
but he turns it into his throne that he always wanted
in basically Loki uses a real big burst of his power
to secure all the timelines
so that they all function together.
They all intertwine, but it winds up looking
just like the world tree.
but it's much more cosmic representation of the world
tree than we've seen before.
so I think the idea is
this is how existence reality was always meant to be.
He was always destined to evolve into this role.
then we go back to the TVA, explained
that is still continuing to function in his old role,
but in a more benevolent way.
Like they're not going around
pruning everybody all the time.
But they are still policing
all the different timelines.
the way that B-15 talks about it.
They're looking mostly for he remains variance
like they're going after the Council of Kangs.
They also bring back Miss Minutes who's been rebooted.
I love the way that Cassie and Hunter B-15
kind of react to Obie when they ask him,
Is she going to rebel against us?
Like is she going to turn into Ultron again
any kind of shrugs?
Like, I don't know, maybe she might.
I that's just them teasing the potential
for more stories with her crossing over into them.
Like we could always use her
as a villain in some future story
if we want when they referenced the war room meeting,
the meeting that they're talking is about deciding
what to do about the Council of Kangs next
And I think this is meant to get into the whole idea of
like what Loki's new powers are like.
If he were that powerful,
like you were essentially God in the Marvel multiverse,
shouldn't he be able to flick his finger
and deal with the Council of Kangs?
So I think the idea is they're just going to explain
that he's not that powerful.
Like there are some limitations on the way he exists
now in the way he helps maintain the timelines.
there's also the idea that the Council of Kangs
exist in their own pocket dimension outside of time.
And if you can only influence stuff
that are in the timelines in the Council of Kangs,
they're not in the timelines. He can't influence them.
Mobius reveals that they just track down another Kang
variant in a616 adjacent universe,
obviously 616 reference to Marvel
comic book universe, but they're kind of saying
that's like the main MCU one, he says.
Adjacent 616 universe.
The whole idea is that it's like a universe.
It's almost like the 616.
Like most of the stuff is the same.
But there are a couple of minor differences.
in the variant of he who remains that
they're talking about actually looks like the events
of Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
with that version of Kang the Conqueror.
So it's almost like they're saying
the events of Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
we're taking in a 616 adjacent universe,
not the main 616.
Universe, which kind of blew my mind just a little bit.
let me know what you thought about that in the comics.
Like, were they actually talking
about the events of Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania?
Like, no, no, no.
This wasn't the real version of Kang the Conqueror.
I think the idea is that they want to introduce
a bigger, better version of Kang the Conqueror,
and that's why they said that the other file
that he's reading that he requested, quote
unquote, is his own file.
Like Mobius, his original file all because he's trying
to learn more about his original life and find a life
for himself on the timeline that's been to pay off
the whole quote about him leaving the TVA temporarily.
I think it's just meant to be temporary
because I think he's supposed to be in Deadpool
three
because the TVA's a big character in Deadpool three.
So at some point he might come back to the TVA done.
In his workshop,
Obi gets a bunch of new copies of his TVA handbook.
Second,
the second edition is just updated with a new way.
The timelines.
The multiverse worked with God of stories
Loki within his multiverse, so to speak.
notice back in his own universe.
Victor Timely no longer gets a copy of the manual.
He just goes on making candles
and probably eventually does something similar.
Like he probably does
something really great eventually, but just does it
on his own steam without any other cheat code manuals.
they finally bring back rents later.
Like this is kind of one of those storylines
that went nowhere for a while.
Like, wait a minute,
what are you going to be a bigger character?
maybe there was a bigger plan for her at one point,
but she wakes up on the Void planet
where we all knew she was going.
But I think there's meant to be a flashback
because she would have gone there immediately
after being pruned.
And that was a couple of episodes ago.
I think that this is meant to be the manhole cover
from the Loki bunker
in season one, implying that she'll survive.
And then she sees the storm coming
in, which is meant to be alive
internal look of determination also makes it seem
like she might learn how to tame allies
like conquer allies in setting her up as a future
bigger villain.
I expect her to appear somewhere in Avengers
five Kang Dynasty.
But there are so many characters during that.
We'll see how they wind up pulling that off
Then Mobius goes back to watch his previous life
with Sylvie,
and it's just meant to play out that moment from Loki,
where he told him he could come back
any time he wanted to.
His old life.
there is he's basically going to go off
and find a life for himself, like make a new life for
on one of the timelines.
Sylvie also makes it sound like when she shrugs like,
what are you going to do next?
She's just going to go around
and have a couple of adventures on her own, too.
She has a temp pad as well
so she can jump around at will.
Then they end on the scene of Loki
as he currently exists in the middle of all reality,
holding all the timelines together with his power
at the center of the world tree,
the center of the multiverse, so to speak.
like I said, the smirk on his face that they end on
is meant to be a mirror for his smirk during Thor
the dark world.
Only this time it's a more polished
like he's smirking at himself, like he's
laughing at a situation like this
is how things worked out during the end credits.
There's only like one brand new scene in
just like previous episodes.
The only thing that changed
are the files at the end of the scene this time,
though, the contents of the files are all moments
from what look like season
one like this is Sylvie in season
one of the Void playing and this is Loki.
During the events of season one episode one.
That's why he's wearing his Avengers outfit.
I think it's the same for the other characters too.
Like this is Hunter B-15
and Cassie's scenes from season one,
and this is probably Mobius from season one as well,
there's still that same thumb holding all the files up.
So I think this is meant to be Hunter B-15 some
there are a lot of you that also asked
about the Post-Credits scene like a secret post-credits
scene at the end of episode five.
the voice was meant to be from the end screen,
like the game over screen from the zany arc
video game, just implying that the game itself was over
and you to stick in some more coins.
So now I know a lot of you are asking
what does this mean for Loki
during Avengers five Kang Dynasty, Secret Wars
because he is so powerful,
shouldn't he be able to be a huge threat
against the Council of Kangs?
I think what they'll do is they'll play
power him a little bit, like they'll explain
that there's some limitations to his abilities
where he can't do things like that.
otherwise there would be no next Avengers
movie, like Loki would just flick his finger
and fix every single in every single movie. but.
They did say that eventually they do plan to reunite
Loki with Thor's like, for instance,
Loki will still continue to be a big character
in future stories like future Avengers stories as well.
although a couple more Avengers videos
for Loki in the next couple of days,
there's a lot to unpack
with all of his new abilities it.
As for Loki, Season three, just the way they end things
in his character, it sounds like something really,
really big would have to change for them
to bring Loki back in to do a new story with them.
so to think if they do Loki season 3,
it would be between Avengers
five Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
or after Secret Wars.
But I do think it was an amazing episode.
Loki is a series is generally series
like one of the best things that Marvel has ever done.
So it'll be a huge disservice to not do more Loki other
funny things some of you may remember from season
one episode one is The End.
This line where they said,
You crazy bureaucrats have no idea how my story ends.
That obviously now being paid off in the finale
for season two, where he becomes
the God of stories changing his own story.
I did a video a couple of days ago about how Loki
in the comics evolved into the God of stories,
like he sort of unlocks this special ability inside him
where he can change his own timeline,
but it doesn't give him the ability
to change the timeline of other characters,
opposed the link for that video down the description
below, there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up.
Like I said, I've got a couple more Loki videos
that I'm working on.
I'll try to post this weekend.
The Marvel's movie is out right now,
so I'll be doing a Post-Credits scene video next.
And like a full breakdown Easter eggs
like I do for all the big movies.
we're also in the middle of Invincible Season
two episodes, and we're supposed to get
what if season two episodes before the end of the year?
That'd be like the next big series that they do.
I'll be doing episode videos for that
just like I did for season one.
click here for my Marvel's
movie Post-Credits scene video.
Update the link as soon as I post that, and click here
for all my other Loki videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!